♪ ♪
>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT, I MARK
STEYN MARK STEYN AND
FORECHECKER.
THERE ARE CONFLICTING REPORTS
TONIGHT ON WHETHER
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A TARGET IN
THE VARIOUS INVESTIGATIONS
ROILING WASHINGTON FROM THE
MUELLER PROBE TO THE MICHAEL
COHEN REINS.
FOR POSSIBLE CRIMINAL CHARGES,
ED HENRY IS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH ALL THE DEVELOPMENTS PAID
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THIS COULD BE A BIG DEAL BECAUSE
WHAT YOU'RE LEARNING TODAY IS AT
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THE OVAL OFFICE MEETING LAST
WEEK TOLD PRESIDENT TRUMP HE IS
NOT A CRIMINAL TARGET AND EITHER
AT THE MICHAEL COHEN
INVESTIGATION OR THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL PROBE INVOLVING ROBERT
MUELLER.
BLOOMBERG KICKED ELVIS OFF BY
REPORTING THAT DURING THIS
MEETING, ROSENSTEIN BASICALLY
SAID TO THE PRESIDENT THAT HE'S
A SUBJECT WOULD MEETING HIS
CONDUCT IS UNDER INVESTIGATION,
BUT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH EVIDENCE
TO CHARGE HIM.
ROSENSTEIN WAS REPORTING THIS
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE COHEN'S
HOME AND OFFICE WERE RATED.
MUELLER IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE HAS
NOT RULED OUT MAKING THE
PRESIDENT A TARGET AT A LATER
DATE BASED ON EVIDENCE THAT
COULD EMERGE, THE SAME COULD
HAPPEN IN COHEN INVESTIGATION
WHICH EXPLAINS WHY TONIGHT THE
PRESIDENT HAS NOW ADDED TO HIS
LEGAL TEAM.
YOU SEE HIM THERE, RUDY
GIULIANI, THE FORMER
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR, FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
HE IS BEEN CRITICAL OF THE FF
ARE GOING LIGHT ON
HILLARY CLINTON, BUT ATTACKING
THE PRESIDENT.
FBI OFFICIALS LIKE ANDREW
McCABE.
THE FORMER NUMBER TWO WHO WAS
FIRED FOR LEAKING AND OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS SENT A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL TO THE U.S. ATTORNEY
HERE IN WASHINGTON SAYING THAT
McCABE TRIED TO COVER ALL OF
THAT UP BY LYING TO THE FBI'S
OWN INVESTIGATORS.
McCABE SAYS TONIGHT HE
BELIEVES HE WILL BE VINDICATED,
BUT IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT
FORMER JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS ARE TELLING US THAT
THE FACT THAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHOSE
NONPARTISAN AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SENT THIS OUT, THIS
CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
IT CARRIES A LOT OF WEIGHT AND
THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
A FEW MOMENTS AGO THAT MAYBE
JAMES COMEY AND ANDREW McCABE
ARE GETTING A DOSE OF THEIR OWN
MEDICINE.
>> Mark: THAT'S PRETTY AMAZING
NEWS, THANKS FOR THAT.
CHRIS IS THE EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
HE'S NOT ONE OF THOSE WHO IS
UNDER CRIMINAL REFERRAL AND TOM
FITTON IS THE PRESIDENT OF
JUDICIAL WATCH.
TOM, THIS IS PRETTY AMAZING.
WE BASICALLY GOT A SITUATION
WHERE THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI IT
WOULD BE THE PRINCIPAL WITNESS
IN THE CRIMINAL PROSECUTION OF
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND POSSIBLY
VICE VERSA IN COMEY'S CASE.
IT'S BIZARRE TIMES.
>> REMEMBER, HE IS THE NUMBER
TWO AT THE FBI OR AT LEAST WAS
NUMBER TWO WITH THE SENIOR
OFFICIAL CHARGED WITH
INVESTIGATING HILLARY CLINTON
OVER THE EMAIL MATTER.
AND TARGETING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED, HIS
CONDUCT HAS BEEN ALLEGED BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, NOW HE'S
FACING POTENTIAL PROSECUTION,
IT'S PAINTED BOAST
INVESTIGATIONS AND REMEMBER,
ANDREW McCABE IRONICALLY IS
THE FBI OFFICIAL WHO REPORTEDLY
SET UP THE AMBUSH INTERVIEW OF
THOSE AGENTS WITH GENERAL FLYNN
AND GENERAL FLYNN WAS LATER
CHARGED WITH LYING AND ADMITTED
TO LYING TO THOSE AGENTS.
NOW MR. McCABE IS NOW CHARGED,
COULD BE CHARGED WITH LYING AT
LEAST THREE TIMES UNDER OATH TO
FBI OFFICIALS.
INCIDENTS ORDINARY DEVELOPMENT
AND IT DOESN'T BODE WELL FOR
MR. McCABE, MR. COMEY, OR
FRANKLY MR. MUELLER WHO IS
HANDED THIS INVESTIGATION BY
McCABE AND HIS TEAM.
>> Mark: IT YOU'RE PRETTY
EMBARRASSED BY THE STATE OF YOUR
OLD AGENCY AND WHAT IT'S COME TO
OLD AGENCY AND WHAT IT'S COME T
TO.
THE FBI IS NOW THE ISSUE.
NOBODY CARES ABOUT RUSSIA,
THAT'S ALL GONE AWAY.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE CONDUCT OF THE
HIGHEST FIGURES IN THE FBI THAT
IS NOW THE ISSUE IN THIS STORY.
>> LET ME JUST SAY, IT'S NOT THE
FBI, THIS IS WHAT MY OP-ED WAS
ABOUT, IT WAS ABOUT NOT EQUATING
THE FBI AND THE GOOD MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE FBI WITH COMEY AND
McCABE, STRZOK, PAGE.
A VERY SMALL GROUP.
REMEMBER, COMEY WAS ONLY
DIRECTOR FOR A VERY SHORT TIME,
SO I HATE TO HAVE THE ENTIRE FBI